yeah it's really just about so I don't
think I think there's a lot of people
that think that technology is inherently
neutral like it's not good or bad but I
think that's not true if you like
compare I know some bio terrorist weapon
which you could event or you could
invent a machine to clean the ocean I
would say I would argue those are not
equally good things to develop so when
technology isn't inheriting neutral it
means it's sort of deterministic so the
inventor kind of puts a certain
direction in the product already and I
think that can be used in our advantage
or to phrase it differently I think
there is a responsibility at with
inventors and entrepreneurs to to build
things that are more good than than bad
and actually plastic I would still argue
that plastic is a net positive
technology and it was once invented as a
solution it saves a lot of weights a lot
of people got hurt when when people use
glass bottles and things like that so
back in the day this was invented as a
as a solution but it has this negative
side effects and then I think we should
now think about well what technologies
can we develop to manage that negative
side effect and probably those have
again a small negative side effect but
you can think about it like a
compounding sort of staircase of of net
positive technologies I think eventually
that's how we can actually solve these
problems so in this country there's a
tremendous amount of recycling but how
effective is that recycling yeah I think
the amount of recycling is actually
pretty lonely in the u.s. compared to to
other countries what countries the best
habit huh
I think like Germany or Switzerland
there's this kind of country there
really and what do they do differently
they just I think they just put more
money in it
and I think most of the waste in the US
is actually being land filled so and
what used to be recycled like she was
sent to China but now like I think this
year last year China said well no we
don't want your waste anymore so so now
I think there will be a lot of
investments in new recycling facilities
in the US now how does that get recycle
okay if you use this water bottle and
you empty and then you throw it in the
recycle container what happens so yeah I
mean very much depends on the location
but to just use an example of where I
live in back in Holland so they yeah
they you actually they collect the
plastic separately then it goes to a
facility where they sort the different
kinds of plastic they get out all the
contaminants and make them into two new
pellets and the problem there is really
the lack of demand for recycled plastic
because I think a lot of companies that
build products because basically
virgin's a new plastic is so cheap
they'd rather just do what they're used
to and not they don't want to see any
risks with their materials so they just
choose for the safe option the new kind
of plastic so I think if you want to do
if you want to promote recycling I would
actually say well promote the use of
recycled material because as long as
there's a demand then you know the price
will go up and then automatically more
recycling would happen yeah there's very
little demand for recycled plastic like
it's not something that you hear about
on a regular basis like people that are
clamoring to get only recycled plastic
yeah and I think that I think maybe
that's that could be another nice side
effect of what we do because yeah we can
kind of make this sort of recycled
plastic a bit more sexy yeah perfect
yeah I think that's exactly it is have
you extended this line of thinking to
other environmental concerns like you
know pollution in terms of like chemical
spills and pollution in the air and
things along those lines yeah
I have quite a few more ideas I would
say but yeah I would really really
wouldn't be good for the OSHA cleanup if
I would get distracted by well I want
you to farm those ideas off to other
people because I think guys like you are
insanely valuable like